- Doja Cat, who I love, just
sampled was it "Walk On By?"
- "Walk On By."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Is that so cool you're
like listening to the songs
like come right back around?
- You know, it's amazing.
I didn't know that it
had been recorded by her.
And my granddaughter called me.
- Wait, they have to ask
permission for that, right?
- No, not really. (laughs)
- Oh! (laughs)
That's a whole separate episode.
- Yeah
- Okay.
- They sample it and it's theirs.
- Oh my gosh.
- But anyway,
my granddaughter called me.
- Yeah.
Asked Grammy. Yeah.
"Do you know you're on
a record with Doja Cat?"
(audience laughs)
I said, "Doja. Who?" (laughs)
And she said, "She's a rapper
and she's a.."
And she was
explaining all of this to me.
- She's great
And I said, "Okay. And what
song are we talking about?"
She said, "'Walk on By'
You're completely
through the entire song."
And, "Okay." Well apparently
it's a major hit for her.
- Oh, no, no. It's huge.
"Paint the Town Red" Yeah.
- Yeah. It's solid hit.
- And I'm thrilled for that.
You know, like I said, when I
heard that it had been done,
"I hope 'Walk On By' is as
good for her as it has been
for me."
- Yeah.
- It's Wonderful.
- I think what's cool
about it too is like...
I'm sorry, you can clap.
You were clapping. Sorry.
(audience applauds and cheers)
I think what's interesting too is,
you know, I grew up on that song.
I love a lot of Burt Bacharach.
Obviously a partner of yours
that you worked with a lot.
But I just think it's cool
'cause, you know, introduce
people like a whole
different generation,
- Yeah.
to songs that they might not have known.
- Absolutely. And they're great songs,
and finally have been exposed to
- Yeah.
some good music.
- Amen. Yes. Yes.